i'm carter and today i'm going to
discuss intelligent document processing
with app sheet automation
let's get started
[Music]
process automation can help with manual
tasks but some of that manual work done
each day requires taking data from a
document like an invoice
and inputting it into another data
source or disparate system
this takes a valuable time that could be
used to focus on high impact work
aptchy combines the power of no code
development with google cloud's
state-of-the-art document ai
to automatically extract and validate
your data you know like invoices
receipts etc
making your workflows more efficient and
free from guesswork all while keeping a
human in the loop
you can think of this intelligent
document processing functionality like a
layer
it sits on top of the automations you
can build currently creating a different
way to trigger automation events or
showcase information in your
applications
from unstructured document data let's
explore an example of how this is done
ben works on a finance team for a large
transportation firm
each week he receives hundreds of
pictures of receipts and pdfs of
invoices that need to be processed for
reimbursements and payments to various
teams across the country these are time
sensitive
he needs a way to keep up with the
increasing number of documents sent his
way
he has access to both google workspace
and app sheet allowing a fast path to a
solution even though he's not a coder
by creating and connecting designated
folders in his google drive account to
his app sheet applications
he'll be able to upload pictures of
receipts and pdfs of invoices
to perform a designated series of
actions for reimbursements he can
trigger both the extraction of the data
and an approval request notification to
his manager all by uploading invoice
and receipt documents to the
pre-selected drive folder
if he really wants to take it to the
next level he can refine the application
experience that houses automation
so he can perform this action from a
mobile device while he's working with
the teams in the field
these benefits don't just need to apply
to those in finance
anyone on your team can create impact by
removing the time spent on document
processing with no code platforms like
app sheet
ready to change how you work get started
by clicking this link
[Music]
you